With this recurrence defined, we are now
ready for the Floyed-Warshall Algorithm.
Note that if we were to simply
implement this with recursion,
we would do a lot of recomputation.
Delta u k, k minus one would be
computed for every vertex v.
And delta k, v,
k minus 1 would be computed for
every vertex u, in every iteration.
As you might have guessed,
we're going to fill out a table.
The sub problems here
have three indices, but
thankfully, only two will be
required for us in the algorithm.
We create a two-dimensional table,
d, indexed by the source and
destination vertices of the path.
We initialize it for k equals 0,
where there are no vertices allowed,
just based on the edges.
Then we add potential
intermediate vertices one by one,
in this outer loop here.
For each source destination pair
we account for the possibility of
using k as an intermediate vertex,
with this update equation.
Note that when i or j is equal to
k this weight here won't change,
since a vertex can't be useful
in the shortest path to itself.
Hence, we don't need to worry about
using outdated value in this loop here.
To extract not just the weights
of the shortest paths, but
also the paths themselves, we keep a
predecessor table, which we'll call pi,
that contains the second to last
vertex on a path from u to v.
Initially, when all paths
are just single edges,
this is just the other
vertex on the incident edge.
In the update phase, we either
leave the predecessor alone, or
if we are going to change the path,
then we switch it to the predecessor of
the second half of the path from k to j.